a California businessman is opening his
heart and wallet to high school students
and teachers after the fire disaster in
the town of Paradise he gave students
and staff at Paradise High School $1,000
each
well altogether the donations told it
totaled more than 1 million dollars and
as Jamie yuccas shows us the men
contributing the money says his only
connection to the school is emotional
smiles have been hard to come by for
these paradise high school students
ever since suffering through the most
devastating wildfire in California
history 90 year old real estate
developer Bob Wilson lives near San
Diego but when he heard about the
hardships these students were enduring
he felt compelled to help about 900 of
the 980 young people attending Paradise
High School lost their homes for me high
school was idyllic time of my life you
might say so I thought about these kids
and I thought about my experience and I
said you know if I can just put a smile
on their face and so I decided on the
spot I would do this
Wilson felt the best way he could have a
personal positive impact was through
individual donations he's giving a
thousand dollar check to all 980
students and their 105 teachers and
staff members and then the more I
thought about it and I thought what
about the whole school what about the
teachers what about the bus driver the
janitor and so forth and so I said I
would include the entire school a lot of
kids will just turn the checks over to
their families for just basic essential
items like food and gas Wilson says
handing out more than a million dollars
is making him feel like a million bucks
let's face it you know there's joy in
giving and especially when you do it
directly he doesn't even know us but he
has it as far
to give us money to us to just help us
and it kind of two hearts mile for CBS
this morning
Jamie yuccas Los Angeles a lot of
smiling hearts in Paradise nice to hear
of a big heart as well when you've lost
everything you know and you have someone
who says here you go here you go no
strings attached just do something for
yourself again shout out to Bob Wilson